herzlich willkommen zur folge 184 des
faz einspruch podcast der wöchentlichen
podcast der faz für recht justiz und
politik heute am dritten november
2021 my name is corinna budras und mit
dabei ist wieder piano rensmann heute
nicht aus köln sondern aus dem camping
office ja herrlich also du sitzt
tatsächlich jetzt mitten im camper ja
ich sind so mitten im camper mit meinem
schönen aufgebauten office hier und ich
hoffe die technik hält ja das hoffen wir
freuen uns auch über nebengeräusche da
lassen wir haben einen ausgang was
möchtet ihr nicht nein
das wird ganz still sein
wir starten gleich mit den themen denn
wir haben heute einen ganzen corona blog
wie es früher immer schon so schöne
tradition war um nummer die highlights
zu nennen die ampel will die cola
beschränkung auf andere rechtliche beine
stellen und ehrlich gesagt wurde da in
der vergangenheit viel unsinn erzählt
also vor allen dingen es in der letzten
woche und wir wollen das mal aufklären
und dann beschäftige fesseln das
auseinander für euch was soll denn jetzt
eigentlich noch gehen und was nicht mehr
genau dass panik angebracht oder nicht
das klima oder später dann beschäftigt
uns der alte streit wieder ob
familiengerichte gegen masken pflicht
abstandsgebot und massen testung an
deutschen schulen vorgehen dürfen
kleiner spoiler dürfen sie nicht aber
das gibt uns die gelegenheit diese
wunderbare boss immer wieder hoch zu
holen weil inzwischen ja auch schon
diverse
bundesgerichte involviert waren also
sprich zuletzt dass ich alles nur wegen
des richters aus weimar genau also sagen
wir mal so das war vielleicht der
bekannteste fall in diesem zusammenhang
klären wir alles nachher und schließlich
hat der bfh also der bundesfinanzhof
einem corona leugner verein die
gemeinnützigkeit abgesprochen also all
das in unserem cola blog aber wir haben
noch mehr wir haben natürlich noch den
ogh der eine rekordstrafe gegen polen
verhängt hat und auf der anderen seite
die
unterricht klage gegen die eu kommission
weil sie quasi noch keine strafen gegen
polen verhängt hat es hilft alles nichts
wir müssen uns mit dem thema weiter
beschäftigen und wir wissen dass noch
einmal so ein bisschen auseinander prima
und dann haben wir noch etwas kommt ne
china wir haben am freitag eine
bundesratssitzung eine relativ dünne
bundesratssitzung aus naheliegenden
gründen aus dem bundestag kommt der
moment nichts aber es gibt eigentlich
eine ganz hübsche idee aus hamburg und
auch bremen hat sich angeschlossen um
die mietpreis um umgehungen der bereits
bremse in zukunft zu verhindern fand ich
ganz süß kann man mal darüber sprechen
denn das thema mietenwahnsinn
beschäftigt uns ja eigentlich immer nur
so im kontext mit den ganz großen team
und also ich sag mal wo eingesetzt
wohnungsgesellschaften enteignen oder so
und man kann es eben auch anders angehen
dass hamburg und bremen jetzt vorhaben
und dann sind wir schon bei unserem
wirklich ganz herrlichen gerechten
urteil hatte freuen wir uns auch darauf
so aber dann geht es jetzt erst mal los
so und jetzt starten wir mit dem
angekündigten corona block der ja aus
der unterschiedlichen dingen diese in
dieser woche besteht und vor allem geht
es uns natürlich in aller erster linie
mal darum was die kommende ich sage es
jetzt einfach mal so
ampelkoalition vorhat in sachen
epidemische lage von nationaler
tragweite die soll aufgehoben werden und
da geht es seit das bekannt wurde in
auch in der berichterstattung in den
medien relativ drunter und drüber wir
haben uns geschaut wir schauen und wir
haben uns gedacht wir schauen uns das
jetzt mal an was das denn eigentlich
bedeutet wenn der 28a
infektionsschutzgesetz aufgehoben wird
ja also das welchen schuldige bitte die
papiere aber wir müssen da präzise sein
denn die epidemische lage von nationaler
tragweite
er wird ja nicht aufgehoben sondern sie
läuft schlicht und ergreifend aus
gerade noch die medien schelte an die
kollegen und schon mache ich den selben
fehler du hast natürlich total recht
purina erklärt wann würden sie auslaufen
warum was bedeutet das und zwar am 25
november ist der tag iks also da stehen
wir dann nach derzeitiger planung
komplett ohne dar da wird also der
bundestag also die treffen sich übrigens
vielleicht das noch mal deutlich zu
sagen der bundestag trifft sich jetzt in
der nächsten woche am kommenden
donnerstag am 10 und dann auch noch mal
am 18 november also in irgendeiner form
wird sich der bundestag dann damit
beschäftigen
aber es steht schon jetzt fest dass er
wohl nicht noch mal feststellen muss
dass es oder feststellen wird dass es
eine epidemische lage von nationaler
tragweite gibt und dass sorgt für viele
stirnrunzeln weil wir ja wissen die
ganzen instanzen steigen ja die es gibt
schon wieder
es gibt schon wieder notlagen auf den
intensivstationen all das wirkt sehr
prekär aber
nichtsdestotrotz das ganze wohl überlegt
sollte man vielleicht an dieser stelle
auch noch mal deutlich sagen also haben
sich die ampel
parteien durchaus auch sehenden auges
darauf verständigt die ein parteien
natürlich bestehend aus spd spd grünen
und der fdp
so und warum heißt jetzt genau wann
fangen wir erstmal an mit dem warum
total richtig
das liegt schlicht und ergreifend daran
dass die epidemische lage von nationaler
tragweite nicht etwa das individuelle
risiko eines jeden einzelnen zu
erkranken betrifft oder beschreiben soll
sondern eigentlich nur eine
zustandsbeschreibung ist die die
öffentliche gesundheit den öffentlichen
gesundheitssektor
umfasst ja und da muss man eben ehrlich
gesagt schon konzertieren seit monaten
haben wir eben also sind wir da schon
lange draußen also das ist schon wegen
der impfungen meinst du wegen der
mittlerweile doch im quote von knapp 70
prozent auf die gesamtbevölkerung das
ist natürlich das wichtigste also wir
haben jetzt ja immer wieder
gebetsmühlenartig das was ich jetzt auf
den intensivstationen
noch was dann noch stattfindet wäre da
noch liegt das sind vor allen dingen
ungeimpfte man sagt jetzt immer es ist
eine pandemie der ungeimpften
90 prozent oder vielleicht sogar mehr
als das sind eben ungeimpfte die
besonders schwere verläufe haben da also
kann man an dieser stelle auch mal
wieder sagen also es einfach ein weiter
beraten
dafür dass die impfung gut funktionieren
ja lasst euch impfen
und letztendlich ist es aber ebenso dass
wir auch schon seit monaten sehen dass
die
stationen nicht überlastet sind ja wir
haben ja jetzt auch schon vor monaten
festgestellt dass war in der letzten und
dann eine der letzten sitzung vor der
bundestagswahl wurde ja dieser katalog
erweitert mit kriterien wann überhaupt
stärkere maßnahmen gezogen werden dürfen
und dass es eben nicht mehr allein die
inzidenz sondern es sind eben auch so
etwas wie die
impfquote oder aber auch die lage an
denen auf den intensivstationen ja da
gibt es ja diese diese berühmte neue
instanz zahl für was jetzt die
intensivstation angeht da weiß man
interessanterweise noch gar nicht genau
wann sich überhaupt wenn die überhaupt
ausgelöst wird also es gibt gar keine
grenzmarke man kann jetzt nicht sagen
bei zehn oder fünfzehn oder wie auch
immer werden neue maßnahmen ergriffen
oder schärfere massnahmen ergriffen
sondern dass es wird immer ja die
referenz genommen zum vergangenen jahr
und da war die höchste zahl es war so
bei 15 also das jetzt sind wir bei unter
vier oder genau dass das zeigt so ganz
eindeutig nicht also die 15er waren wir
sehr sehr an der grenze
sehr an der grenze auch zur triage zudem
zu der phase den die wir niemals hin
wollte nämlich dass den menschen nicht
mehr geholfen werden kann die da in not
auf der intensivstation
liegen und oder zumindest nicht alle so
und daher wollen wir davon aus dass
diese lage nicht mehr besteht weil wir
so eine hohe impfquote haben und dass
wir deshalb auch die epidemische lage
von nationaler tragweite nicht
verlängern müssen richtig genau und da
könnte man jetzt natürlich einwenden
naja aber im öffentlich rechtlichen
rundfunk oder aber auch in vielen
anderen nachrichten
[Musik]
nachrichtensendungen ist er jetzt immer
die rede davon von überlastungen auf den
intensivstationen von prekären
situationen von pflegern die komplett
erschöpft sind und auch nicht mehr
können ja das alles ist ja richtig aber
man muss vielleicht dazu sagen ist eine
punktuelle sicht auf die dinge
genau also natürlich kann man da immer
sozusagen nur situative berichte
einholen von betroffenen und das ist ja
auch klar dass zum beispiel in bayern
sind durch die krankenhäuser schon
wesentlich voller wieder aber natürlich
auch nicht alle bayerischen
krankenhäuser sind schon jetzt über
laufen oder in einem kritischen zustand
aber ich glaube schon dass man darauf
hinweisen muss dass das sich trotz lockt
downs nur der ungeimpften einander lockt
uns trotz pandemie nur der ungeimpften
in anführungszeichen sich die dinge
ändern können nun also ich glaube schon
dass es jetzt nicht so easy going sein
muss wie jens spahn sich jetzt eben
hingestellt hat der noch amtierende
gesundheitsminister und gesagt hat jetzt
brauchen wir eigentlich die epidemische
lage von nationaler tragweite nicht mehr
wir brauchen diese maßnahmen nicht mehr
anzuordnen ich glaube da sind wir uns
nicht ganz einig corinna aber ich möchte
doch diesen diesen hinweis an der stelle
unterbringen das ist im moment eine eine
momentaufnahme die dinge können sich
wieder ändern es gibt aber natürlich
schon sehr realistische naja
anhaltspunkte dafür dass es nicht so
schlimm wird wie im vergangen ja das mal
zu erklären wir haben natürlich schon im
vorfeld ordentlich also gestritten ist
jetzt wirklich übertrieben wir haben das
für streit mehr hingenommen weil also
meiner meinung nach ist wir sind jetzt
tatsächlich in der situation wo wir ein
etwas ungünstiges signal senden ja oder
wo die ampel damit ein ziemlich
ungünstiges signal sendet aber ich finde
da muss ich gesundheitsministerien
sparen an die eigene nase fassen denn
eigentlich hätte es schon im sommer die
epidemische lage von nationaler
tragweite gar nicht verlängert werden
dürfen da würde ich mich dem anschließen
was der rechtswissenschaftler thorsten
kingreen zum beispiel bei auf dem
verfassungs block in einem sehr
interessanten beitrag geschrieben hat ne
also im grunde aber schon die letzte
verlängerung eigentlich
grenzwertig beziehungsweise er geht so
weit zu sagen dass sie rechtswidrig war
dass man das nicht hätte tun dürfen und
im sommer hätte also das war eben vor
drei monaten wann man ist das also
gewesen im august da hätte man das auch
mit wesentlich mehr werfer kaufen können
das wäre auch ein gängiger gewesen und
jetzt hat man leider weil damals die
zahlen so niedrig weil die zahlen so
niedrig waren genau dass wir haben ja
doch einen relativ entspannten sommer
wieder hinter uns gebracht ja wie ist ja
auch abzusehen waren und da hätte man
das schon zurücknehmen können und hätte
also jetzt rede ich auch so als hätte
ganz auslaufen lassen können ja und das
hat man sich aber da hat man sich
dagegen entschieden und zwar mit blick
auf die bundestagswahl weil man da nicht
mehr klasse finde ich durchaus auch ein
tragfähiges argument ist wenn man sagt
na ja wir wissen ja nicht wie lange dann
nachher koalitionsverhandlungen
stattfinden oder so und für den fall
dass alle zahlen wieder explodieren und
dann dinge irgendwie relativ schnell
angeordnet werden müssen verlängern wir
es noch mal um die drei monate die eben
in gesetzen gehen findet nicht länger
also ein tragfähiges argument finde ich
wirklich nicht da muss ich vehement
widersprechen denn das ist nicht das was
die epidemische lage von nationaler
tragweite meint sie meint nicht wir sind
kurz vor der wahl und haben nach
handlungsunfähige bundesregierung die
wir ja übrigens auch nicht haben also
wir haben ja immer noch eine
geschäftsfähige und geschäftsführende
bundesregierung und vor allen dingen wir
haben ein parlament das sich
konstituiert und man muss ja auch sagen
jetzt recht technisch ist es ja auch so
dass sie jetzt ja hier die fraktion
tätig werden so sind die fraktionen von
fdp spd und grüne die hier was vorlegen
die bitten so ist der mechanismus das
gesundheitsministerium
formulierungshilfe aber es ist ja nicht
so als wären wir komplett führungslos
und handlungs los ja und da finde ich
hat sich das haben sich die parteien die
politik sich das einfach ein bisschen zu
einfach gemacht und haben finde ich auch
wir haben sind ein bisschen zu lax damit
umgegangen was jetzt vielleicht auch der
tatsache geschuldet ist dass wir schon
seit anderthalb jahren beziehungsweise
auch schon seit 20 monaten jetzt mit
dieser epidemischen lage
hantieren da haben wir uns ein bisschen
dran gewöhnt und ich finde also ich
hatte mehr verständnis dafür wenn das
wirklich an die gegebenheiten angepasst
wird wenn sie quasi zurück genommen wird
oder eben nicht verlängert wird in dem
moment wo die zahlen so niedrig sind und
wenn man dann ich habe zum beispiel auch
kein problem damit wenn die zahlen
wieder hoch gehen oder wir wirklich eine
prekäre situation haben dann das wieder
vom bundestag feststellen zu lassen ja
also das hätte ich sozusagen auch eine
einen gangbaren weg gefunden und wie
gesagt der bundestag als solcher ist er
handlungsfähig
also ihr merkt es schon da draußen die
kritiker kritisieren ja im moment ist
sei zu früh um die epidemische lage von
nationaler tragweite auslaufen zu lassen
und corinna ist eigentlich mit durchaus
namhaften rechtswissenschaftlerin und
rechtswissenschaftlern gemeinsam der
auffassung eigentlich sind wir schon zu
spät damit wir hätten sie schon im
sommer auslaufen lassen müssen ja und
das bedeutet übrigens nicht um das
deutlich zu sagen dass wir es hier jetzt
mit einem freedom day zu tun haben da
kommen wir jetzt ja nämlich dazu es ist
ja nicht so als wären dann gar keine
möglichkeiten mehr da als könnte die
politik nicht handeln als können die
politik keine maßnahmen ergreifen das
gegenteil der fall sondern was die ampel
koalition die sie dennoch nicht gibt ja
also die ampel parteien ja machen wollen
ist ja das ganze eben nur auf andere
rechtliche füße zu stellen und da gibt
es glaube ich auch in einer reihe von
namhaften wissenschaftlern
rechtswissenschaftlern die sagen das ist
klug und längst überfällig dass man sich
jetzt nicht mehr auf dieses konstrukt
verlässt in dem 28a
infektionsschutzgesetz darum geht es ja
immer also um das vielleicht noch mal zu
erklären man hat diesen mechanismus dass
die epidemische lage von nationaler
tragweite
erklärt wird und dann gelten sozusagen
gibt es eine latte von maßnahmen von
abstandsgebot
und masken pflicht über aber auch
wesentlich härtere maßnahmen wie
ausgangssperre kontakt beschränkungen
oder auch den berühmten lockdown also
die schließung von
lokalen restaurants kinos fitnessstudios
und so weiter und so fort das findet
sich alles um 28 a
und was jetzt gemacht wird ist darauf
jetzt erstmal nicht zurück zu greifen
sondern zu sagen wir nehmen uns nur
kleine handvoll von maßnahmen die aber
am effektivsten sind also konkret die
masken pflicht und das abstandsgebot
und verankern das im
also können und zwar unabhängig von der
epidemischen lage von nationaler
tragweite die können also grundsätzlich
gelten und zwar auch das ist jetzt erst
mal befristet bis zum 20 märz 2022 also
frühlingsanfang genau und das soll dann
auch eine dass sonja maßnahmen werden
die die länder dann verhängen können
aber so ist es ja immer dass da mal
nicht vergessen es sind immer eigentlich
die länder die letztendlich auch bisher
schon die maßnahmen verhängt haben genau
ausnahme einzige ausnahme war die
berühmte bundes notbremse wo dann
tatsächlich mal auf bundesebene
eingeschritten wurde ansonsten sind es
die länder und tatsächlich reagieren die
ampel koalitionäre ja damit auch auf
relativ massive über massive beschwerden
aus den ländern die dann sehr schnell
kam wo die länder gesagt haben leute wir
brauchen aber doch noch irgendwelche
maßnahmen die wir verhängen können und
jetzt ist tatsächlich eben der plan
relativ konkrete maßnahmen den länder
weiterhin zu ermöglichen also nicht mehr
so einen riesigen katalog der dann quasi
potenziell möglich ist und schnell mal
irgendwie verabschiedet werden kann
sondern die länder sollen sehr punktuell
maßnahmen ergreifen können die richtig
konkret formulieren sind corinna dass es
gerade schon gesagt massen pflicht
hygiene konzepte sollen auch weiterhin
gelten abstandsgebot natürlich ebenfalls
aber eben auch die quasi 2g oder 3g
regelungen also dabei soll es weiter
bleiben können mit der möglichkeit zu
kapazitäten beschränkungen der
beschränkung des zugangs was verstehst
du darunter ja ganz klar zweig bzw drei
gene also dass auch das war ein großer
großes missverständnis in der
vergangenen woche der hieß es plötzlich
das sei gar nicht mehr möglich das ist
natürlich quatsch wir streben ja die
ganze zeit dahin oder haben wir ja auch
gebetsmühlenartig deutlich gemacht dass
es tatsächlich darauf ankommt die die
weiterverbreitung des virus einzudämmen
und das geht natürlich sehr gut durch
eine impfung ja da kann ja nicht sagen
dass die impf lasst dann gar nicht
weitergegeben wird aber sie wird doch in
so reduzierten maße weiter gegeben dass
man sagen kann und dass das rk ii das
robert koch institut deutlich macht dass
geimpfte keinen wesentlichen beitrag
mehr leisten für die verbreitung des
virus so und da haben wir ja den ganzen
regeln also 2g und 3g
festgestellt die können jetzt schon
verhängt werden also oder eingesetzt
werden von den betrieben oder also von
den betrieben nicht sondern von den
restaurants zum beispiel also von von
kinos und so weiter und so fort und auch
das ist natürlich weiterhin möglich und
wird sogar auch verschärft also wir
haben ja zum beispiel in sachsen wo die
situation ja besonders brenzlig ist wo
es auch ganz besonders eine ganz
besonders niedrige impfquote gibt haben
wir jetzt die nachricht dass die korona
verordnung noch mal verschärft werden
soll und da jetzt die zweijährige
flächendeckend verhängt werden muss also
zb in der innen gastronomie beim zugang
zur veranstaltung und festen im kultur
und freizeitbereich in diskotheken und
bars und so weiter und so fort vorne
können auch nochmal klarzustellen in all
diese bereiche hätten dann nur noch
geimpfte und genesene zutritt und
niemand mehr der umkämpfte und auch
nicht frei getestet quasi was es künftig
aber nicht mehr geben soll das sollten
wir vielleicht einmal auch noch deutlich
sagen ist dass es keinen
flächendeckenden und pauschalen lockdown
mehr geben soll keine schulschließung
und keine flächendeckenden kontakt
beschränkungen und warum macht man das
auch da ist zb
katrin göring eckardt von den grünen
auch sehr deutlich gewesen die
befürchten einfach dass ich das eben
nicht mehr durchhalten lässt bei einer
impfquote von zwei drittel der
gesamtbevölkerung ja die können
durchhalten mainz so rechtlich
durchhalten genau richtig die das
besteht ganz klar die befürchtungen dass
gerichte diese maßnahmen dann kippen
würden und das würde natürlich zu neuer
unruhe führen und vor allen dingen was
jetzt auch die rechtliche und
rechtssicherheit angeht das war
natürlich in der tat auch eine
schwierige situation im vergangenen
jahres und ständig irgendwie was
beherbergungs verbote zum beispiel
verhängt die dann wenig später gekippt
wurden von den gerichten das natürlich
ein bisschen unerfreulich so aber was es
stattdessen gibt ist natürlich punktuell
na also punktuelle eingriffe
selbstverständlich kann in einer schule
wo es einen massenausbruch gegeben hat
die schule geschlossen werden ja für
einen für einen bestimmten punkt das
sind dann oder für einen bestimmten
zeitraum das sind dann eben
maßnahmen die individuell verhängt
werden können können auch genau so wie
er ist ja auch weiterhin natürlich
quarantäne anordnungen geben kann für
menschen die potenziell gefährlich sind
nun also mit potenzielle sozusagen
überträger der krankheit sein können
auch das bleibt alles weiterhin möglich
genau ich glaube damit hätten wir jetzt
einen ganz guten überblick gegeben über
das was die ampel vor hat oder haben wir
noch was vergessen
ich glaube dass relevante ist drin wie
gesagt wechsel unter der unterricht das
könnte alles möglich bleiben es ist also
keinesfalls so dass wir irgendwie einen
freedom day kriegen hier zum ende
november sondern frühestens wird alles
fallen im am 20 märz 2022 und bis dahin
ist noch lange hin ich glaube wir
schauen mal wie punktuell der überblick
ist den wir jetzt gerade haben und was
da so kann die nex auch da übrigens noch
einmal der hinweis zum 20 dritter zum 20
märz auch da hat die fdp zb ganz
deutlich gesagt das ist natürlich stand
jetzt mehr auf dem stand der
informationen die wir jetzt haben also
auch da ist es jetzt nicht so dass man
quasi
wieder sehenden auges in eine ungewisse
situation
rennen sondern natürlich können
maßnahmen wenn sie nötig sind auch
verlängert werden übrigens kann
jederzeit natürlich auch die epidemische
lage von nationaler tragweite wieder
aufgenommen werden wieder festgestellt
werden wenn die lage so ist aber es ist
insofern neues signal als dass das nicht
mehr automatisch passiert wie es eben in
den vergangenen 20 monaten uhr fast
automatisch aber wir hören jetzt auf
damit darüber zu streiten und kommt zu
unserem nächsten thema wo wir eben noch
in unserem corona blog bleiben und der
bgh hat eine entscheidung getroffen zum
thema worüber dürfen familiengerichte
eigentlich erscheint ja und da kann ich
mal eine zentrale erkenntnis verkünden
familiengerichte sind nicht der richtige
ort um die masken pflicht an schulen zu
kippen auch nicht das abstandsgebot oder
die testpflicht was ziemlich banal
klingt war
umstritten sagen wir mal so freundlich
ausgedrückt
da klicken wir auch noch mal zurück auf
diverse episoden die constantin von
innen und ich im frühjahr hier
absolviert haben wo wir uns schon sehr
intensiv mit dem amtsgericht weimar
beschäftigt haben davon da ging eben das
signal aus das ist anders sein könnte ja
und auch hier ist es wichtig für alle
juristisch interessierten ohne
juristisches staatsexamen davon haben
wir auch viele hören und hörer das ist
ein wunderbares beispiel dafür nämlich
wie juristen um die ecke denken um nicht
zu sagen tricksen ja um an das
gewünschte ziel zu kommen und das ist
immer hilfreich wenn man es durchschauen
kann hier so ein kleiner werbeblock für
juristische kenntnisse er tut auch nicht
weh
na ja manchmal schon endlich gesagt aber
es bringt am ende total ja also erzähl
mal wie haben die damals versuche also
an dieser weimarer fall wurde dann ja
wirklich richtig bekannt aber es war ja
nicht der einzige fall sondern es gab ja
tatsächlich wie so eine art welle ich
sage es jetzt einfach mal hässlich von
corona leugnen oder zumindest corona
maßnahmen gegnern die versuch haben zu
familiengerichten zu gehen um corona
maßnahmen an schulen zu kippen ja und
das ist natürlich auch teil des dilemmas
na also um wir sind jetzt quasi ein
halbes jahr später und haben jetzt die
erkennen dass die jetzt der bgh letzte
woche ventiliert hat ja aber um das zu
klären wurden mitunter diverse familie
und verwaltungsgerichte eingeschaltet
oberlandesgerichte und
oberverwaltungsgerichte so wie eben die
höchsten instanzen
bundesverwaltungsgericht und
bundesgerichtshof ja übrigens auch ein
deutliches zeichen dafür dass wir in
einem rechtsstaat leben und der durchaus
auch funktioniert aber manchmal dauert
es eben so ein bisschen länger ja so und
jetzt kommen wir arbeit zu weimar ja da
ging es um ein frei wo eine mutter für
ihre söhne
anordnen lassen wollte dass die sich in
der schule nicht mehr der masken pflicht
unterziehen müssen also die wollte
verhindern dass ihre kinder masken
tragen müssen dass sie sich ans
abstandsgebot halten müssen und dass sie
auch nicht getestet werden ja das alles
wollte sie vor dem familiengericht
einklagen und jetzt wird eben schön über
den paragrafen 100
1666 bgb also die gefährdung des
kindeswohls ja also da muss man auch
erstmal drauf kommen ja denn
normalerweise geht man natürlich wenn
man sich gegen korona maßnahmen wären
möchte die ja von staatlicher seite
angeordnet werden zu den
verwaltungsgerichten das heißt es ist
schon relativ tricky zu sagen hier geht
es aber ums wohl meiner kinder ich
stütze mich aufs bürgerliche gesetzbuch
und gehe damit zum familien- und man
kann er übrigens noch mal sagen die
verwaltungsgerichte wurden ja durchaus
eingeschalteten nur die haben relativ
grundsätzlich immer die quasi für die
masken pflicht plädiert weil es ja auch
eine relativ
geringe geringer eingriff ist ja in die
rechte der kinder und überhaupt alte der
maskenträger schlechthin und deswegen
war man da nicht besonders erfolgreich
aber bei den familiengerichten erhoffte
man sich eben mehr durchaus auch zu
recht wie wir dann erfahren
und zwar eben über den 1666 bgb und
denen die sich vielleicht noch mal vor
weise schön wär s ja absatz 1 wird das
körperliche geistige oder seelische wohl
des kindes oder sein vermögen gefährdet
und sind die eltern nicht gewinnt oder
nicht in der lage die gefahr abzuwenden
so hat das familiengericht die maßnahmen
zu treffen die zur abwendung der gefahr
erforderlich sind ist natürlich
im ganz anderen kontexten normalerweise
der fall so wenn es wirklich um
körperliche züchtigung geht um sexuellen
missbrauch
dann schreiten die familiengerichte ein
um das kindeswohl zu retten und insofern
war das hier wirklich eine ziemlich
innovative
maßnahme da hier zu ergreifen und dann
sind sie eben auch auf einem absatz 4
gegangen in angelegenheiten der
personensorge kann das gericht auch
massnahmen mitwirkung ging einen dritten
treffen also hier eben mit wirkung gegen
die schule das war die rechtliche
konstruktion ja
also das familiengericht das amtsgericht
weimar oder insbesondere eben ein
konkreter richter hat sich darauf
eingelassen
man hört auch das ist der absprache im
vorfeld gegeben hat oder dass man auch
relativ gezielt diesen richter
ausgesucht hat so möchte ich mal
formulieren also die anwälte haben
wirklich relativ unverhohlen dem netz
auch für solche art von klagen geworben
und haben gesagt wir kennen uns da aus
und wissen wie wir es machen sollen der
erfolg ist ihnen gewiss also es war
wirklich auch das waren konzertierte
aktion ganz klar so und das amtsgericht
hat noch mitgemacht aber die oberen
instanzen also dann war der schrei der
empörung auch wirklich so unfassbar groß
dass zum beispiel das oberlandesgericht
jena eingeschritten ist im mai und
gesagt hat hier gab es eine unglaubliche
amtsanmaßung die verwaltungsgerichte
sind dafür zuständig und da hat da also
schlichtweg das den beschluss aufgehoben
er hat den rechtsweg zu den ordentlichen
gerichten für unzulässig erklärt und das
verfahren eigentlich also das war eben
der beschluss des oberlandesgerichts
jena und der hat dann natürlich auch
signalwirkung entfaltet aber auch das
bundesverwaltungsgericht wurde dann noch
eingeschaltet also dazu muss man eben
sagen das auch gleichzeitig natürlich
das verwaltungsgericht weimar dann
eingeschaltet wurde die haben dann gegen
diese masken pflicht oder zugunsten der
masken pflicht entschieden also ihr sind
eben den ganz anderen weg gegangen als
das familiengericht und da wo war schon
deutlich dass es hier eine fundamentalen
widerspruch gibt und sehr
unterschiedliche auffassung also wir
sagen die verwaltungsgerichte waren
relativ klar in diesem zusammenhang
haben immer wieder gesagt also masken
pflicht dagegen ist wenig einzuwenden
bei den die familiengerichte oder das
familiengericht war und auch andere in
der republik mussten eben
zurückgepfiffen werden und sagen und
zwar mit dem hinweis ihr seid nicht
zuständig jetzt hat auch jüngst noch das
bundesgericht der bundesgerichtshof
seinen senf dazugeben müssen das war ein
bisschen anders gelagerter fall bei
ähnlicher sachverhalt nur dass die
gerichte nicht mitspielten dabei aber
auch nicht den mut hatten die sache
dauerhaft zu begraben sondern die den
fall so ein bisschen wie eine heiße
kartoffel hin und her geschoben haben
daraufhin unfall in wesel und da gab es
auch wieder eine familie die das
durchsetzen wollte auf basis von § 166
bgb
1666 bgb
also gefährdung des kindeswohls da ging
es um ein 15 jähriges mädchen
und da haben die familiengerichte oder
das zuständige oder das familiengericht
das da angerufen wurde nur festgestellt
dass sie nicht zuständig sind also hat
den rechtsweg zu den ordentlichen
gerichten für unzulässig erklärt und
anstatt das dann einzustellen haben sie
das verfahren an das verwaltungsgericht
verwiesen ja und die wiederholen wollten
damit auch nichts zu tun haben und
machen das an das familiengericht
zuständigkeitshalber
zurückgesandt
super jura nord wort übrigens ja richtig
naja und
also an alles ein riesen hin und her und
das lustige ist es dann tatsächlich wenn
gerichts zweigs übergreifen zwei
gerichte sich nicht einigen können ob
sie nicht zuständig sind mit negativen
kompetenz konflikt dann kommen direkt
die bundesgerichte ins spiel das heißt
dann kann jedes dieser gerichte
sozusagen sein zuständiges bundesgericht
anrufen in diesem fall eben einmal das
bundesverwaltungsgericht und jetzt eben
der bgh ja und die haben da auch kurzen
prozess gemacht und hat gesagt also hier
gibt es gar keine befugnis des
familiengerichts zum erlass einer
solchen anordnung und die haben auch
noch mal deutlich gemacht was vielleicht
offensichtlich vorher nicht ganz klar
war ja aber schulen sind schon überhaupt
gar keine dritten ja also wir erinnern
uns eben habe ich sehr erklärt dass das
familiengericht einschreiten kann wenn
eine gefährdung des kindeswohls
vorliegt und da auch dritte
eingebunden werden können aber für
schulen gilt das nicht und übrigens auch
nicht für jugendämter ämter also für
alle behörden staatliche behörden geht
das nicht weil es dafür schlicht und
ergreifend keine gesetzliche grundlage
gibt ja und deswegen wäre es ein
eingriff in die gewaltenteilung ja und
es schon das haben sie jetzt klar
gestellt also diese ganze konstruktion
fällt
in sich zusammen
komplett
damit sie mir durch oder ja dann sind
wir durch also allerdings noch lange
nicht mit dem corona block nicht dass
ihr jetzt denkt das wäre es schon
gewesen wir haben auch noch den
bundesfinanzhof und einen ja man kann es
so hässlich ausdrücken corona opfer ein
dieser verein hat entscheidung von
vergangener woche seine gemeinnützigkeit
verloren weil er eben mit corona laut na
ja ich sag mal aufrufen und maßnahmen
tätig geworden ist und ich würde gern
einmal bevor wir in das urteil
einsteigen klären was heißt das denn
eigentlich genau wenn ein verein seine
gemeinnützigkeit verlieren ja das ist
auch noch ein wichtiger hinweis denn es
geht hier natürlich nicht darum ob
dieser verein verboten wird oder nicht
mehr auch das könnte natürlich für
missstimmung sorgen weil die gene die
sowieso fürchten dass der rechtsstaat
hier weit über seine grenzen
auf corona kritische menschen einschlägt
so ist es ja überhaupt nicht sondern es
geht lediglich um die gemeinnützigkeit
also um ein steuerprivileg ja und dazu
muss man wissen dass vereine sich eben
gemeinde sich die gemeinnützigkeit
anerkennen lassen können ja
und zwar ist das geregelt in paragraf 52
abgehoben abgabenordnung und das ist
insofern auch ein ganz lustiger paragraf
weil da wie die ganzen zwecke
aufgelistet sind die der
gemeinnützigkeit dienen also dem der
gesellschaft dem wohl der öffentlichkeit
und so und da sind ganz interessante
dinge dabei ist natürlich sport raus und
runter dann allerdings auch so was wie
der förderung der unterhaltung und
pflege von friedhöfen es auch so ein
geschützter zweck zur pflege der
religion fürsorge von strafgefangenen
heimatpflege und ortsverschönerung
so und wenn man das erlangt hat die
gemeinnützigkeit ist das ziemlich gut
weil dann hat man eben steuerliche
privilegien und vor allen dingen kann
man das auch den spendern dann so
verkauf und sagen man kann dann
spendenquittungen ausstellen vor allem
an wänden quittung und dann ist das
attraktiver für diesen verein zu spenden
weil man dann wiederum seine eigene
seine eigene steuerlast mindern kann da
also wenn ich dem
gemeinnützigen verein was ich spende
100 euro spendet dann kann ich das von
der steuer absetzen und das mindert
natürlich meine eigene steuerlast so und
deswegen sagen auch viele vereine dass
sie davon abhängig sind weil nur dass
viele spender anzieht und jedes mal wenn
es dann zu einem verlust der
gemeinnützigkeit kommt ist das ein
schwarzer tag für solche vor einem so
und hier war es auch so
also der 52 abgabenordnung den chor in
agrarischen zitiert hat nennt eben
ausdrücklich sehr viele lustige zwecke
die man verfolgen muss kann darf und es
geht ja schon auch also es darf damit
auch einher gehen dass man gewisse
politische ziele verfolgt oder goya also
hier in diesem konkreten fall ging es
natürlich um die förderung des
öffentlichen
gesundheitswesen jetzt muss ich noch mal
ganz kurz gucken was sie
was sie hatte
eingetragene ziel war dass eingetragene
ziel war das war die förderung des
öffentlichen gesundheitswesens sowie die
förderung des allgemeinen demokratischen
staatswesen das war das erklärte ziel
ist schon etwas anderes als pflege
irgendwie keine ahnung man unser dorf
soll schöner werden
da würde ich das auch nicht klein reden
möchte an dieser stelle auf keinen fall
aber das interessante ist eben
finanzämter lesen auch zeitungen oder
gucken ins netz und überprüfen ob die
vereine diesem ziel auch gerecht werden
ja und wenn dabei dann recht
interessante dinge auf der internetseite
von dem verein genau denn die haben ihm
tatsächlich wirklich
falschinformation staatlichen corona
maßnahmen verbreitet haben gesagt so
masken ring eigentlich überhaupt gar
nichts bei der bekämpfung der pandemie
ansonsten was aber noch also es ging
wirklich ziemlich hoch her mein favorit
war dass dort hingewiesen wurde auf das
recht zum widerstand nach 21 absatz 4
des grundgesetzes für den fall dass es
weitere corona also die korona maßnahmen
staatlicherseits geben sollte
letztendlich hat auch ein
vorstandsmitglied des vereins im
zusammenhang mit der bekämpfung der
pandemie von der möglichen abhängigkeit
von politikern von anderen mächten
gesprochen also auch so ein bisschen
also ein bisschen ist gut
also verschwörungstheorien in umlauf
gebracht so und all das fand das
finanzamt jetzt nicht so lustig und in
dessen folge auch ihm der bfh nicht und
der bfh der bundesfinanzhof hat jetzt
eben deutlich gesagt dass das mit den
zwecken überhaupt gar nichts zu tun hat
denn um diese zwecke zu erfüllen die
genannten zwecke zu erfüllen muss sich
eine körperschaft umfassend mit den
demokratischen grundprinzipien befassen
und diese geistige offenheit
objektiv und neutral würdigen so und
geistige offenheit
habe dieser verein nicht da ich finde
das kann sich ganz gut hören lassen wenn
man ernsthaft die abhängigkeit von
politiker von anderen mächten vertritt
oder auch mal irgendwie auf das recht
zum widerstand aus dem grundgesetz
hinweist wenn es um corona maßnahmen
geht das ist lässt sich gut hören ja und
da könnte man auch dann wieder darauf
hinweisen dass das auch wahrlich nicht
die erste entscheiden ist die in diese
richtung geht das problem ist
tatsächlich viel älter als corona denn
es gibt schon eine grundsatz
entscheidung des bfh aus dem jahre 20 19
wo es die wir ganz schön viel aufregung
gesorgt damals nicht genau wo es um die
globalisierungskritische organisation
attac ging ja und es schont attac hatte
der bfh die gemeinnützigkeit aberkannt
oder zumindest sagen wir mal so das
passierte natürlich dann in den unteren
instanzen die haben quasi die
marschrichtung ausgegeben
und zwar ging es da um die frage wie
politisch aktiv diese vereine überhaupt
sein können und dürfen um weiterhin
gemeinnützig zu sein ja und da hat der
bfh ziemlich deutlich gesagt dürfen sie
eigentlich dich ja sagen gerade bei
attac und dann auch in dessen folge zum
beispiel kompakt eine ähnliche
organisationen die die in dessen folge
auch ihre gemeinnützigkeit verloren hat
die sind einfach zu politisch aktiv und
das ist eben kein zweck der in § 52 der
abgabenordnung festgelegt wäre ja also
das könnte man so machen ja aber steht
eben nicht drin das dazu sei dann eine
gesetzesänderung notwendig und das ist
auch in der tat etwas was
bundesfinanzminister olaf scholz dann
beschäftigt hat aber bisher ist ihm
dieser paragraph der abgabenordnung noch
nicht dahingehend
geändert weil es eben einfach einen
großen streit darüber geht soll man
diesen diesen
verein auch die politische betätigung
erlauben so und das war natürlich in dem
zusammenhang mit attac damals hieß es
dann natürlich sehr schnell dass es
nicht um jede politische zielsetzungen
gehe weil eben nicht irgendeine irgend
einfach ein verboten wird sondern eben
attac und da steht dann schwebt
natürlich immer oben drüber der staat
will natürlich irgendwie will will
niemanden quasi niemandem steuervorteile
anbieten oder den unterstützen dessen
politische zielsetzung ihm am ende nicht
gefällt so steht es natürlich nicht in
irgendwelchen urteilen drin im moment
ist es einfach fakt dass man eine
gesetzesänderung bräuchte nach der
rechtsprechung des bfh im moment um zu
sagen na ja zu viel politische
zielsetzungen und politischer aktivismus
kann man glaube ich eher sagen das geht
dann doch zu weit und das wollen wir
zumindest nicht mehr steuerlich fördern
noch mal es geht hier nur um die
steuerliche förderung seitens das
schaffen vielleicht noch ein letztes um
das noch einmal deutlich zu machen also
der bfh hat auch danach dem attac urteil
noch einmal seine rechtsprechung ein
bisschen aufgeweicht hat gesagt na ja
also es jetzt nicht so dass jetzt jede
politische betätigung
nicht erlaubt ist
aber sie muss zur erreichung des
satzungsmäßigen zwecks erforderlich
seien ja und auch das haben sie hier
wieder erholt wiederholt und auch dass
es hier nicht gegeben das heißt dieser
verein ist jetzt dauerhaft nicht
gemeinnützig aber damit werden wir doch
jetzt endlich am ende unseres
kohleblocks angekommen
[Musik]
so dann kommen wir zu einem ganz anderen
thema aber eins das uns auch schon seit
langem beschäftigt denn der ogh der
europäische gerichtshof hat jetzt eine
rekordstrafe gegen polen verhängt was
war da los
rekordstrafe kann man schon so sagen
eine millionen euro pro tag muss polen
jetzt zahlen und ich möchte erstmal den
vize-präsidenten des euro hat dazu
zitieren das hält er für erforderlich um
einen schweren und nicht wieder
gutzumachenden schaden für die
rechtsordnung der europäischen union und
die werte auf denen diese union beruht
insbesondere den der rechtsstaatlichkeit
abzuwenden wir hören schon an der
rhetorik in der eskalationsspirale
zwischen sammer polen und dem rest der
welt na ja wohin und dem rest der eu
geht es immer weiter aufwärts worum geht
es mal wieder um die polnische
sogenannte disziplinarkammer am obersten
gericht das ist so eines der
hauptelemente der polnischen
justizreform die jetzt eigentlich schon
seit jahren in streit steht diese
disziplinarkammer ist zuständig für
disziplinarverfahren gegen richterinnen
und richter und zwar nicht nur am
obersten gericht sondern die ist auch
die berufungsinstanz für die
disziplinarverfahren gegen alle
richterinnen und richter in polen und
was kann die machen ja ungefähr alles
also sie kann die immunität der richter
aufheben sie kann gehälter kürzen sie
kann die richter vom dienst suspendieren
und sie kann vor allem die richterinnen
und richter entlassen da wurde natürlich
schon relativ schnell gesagt okay das
entspricht jetzt nicht gerade dem was
die eu und ihre und ihre und ihr
wertekatalog sich unter einem
rechtsstaat vorstellen deshalb gibt es
seit oktober 2009 10 ein
vertragsverletzungsverfahren der
eu-kommission gegen polen und schon im
rahmen einer einstweiligen anordnung im
april 2020 hat der ogh polen
aufgefordert die arbeit der
disziplinarkommission auszusetzen das
ist nicht passiert da hieß es dann so ja
ja die machen wir nicht mehr weiter
haben sie aber doch sie haben zwar keine
neuen fälle angenommen aber alte fälle
abgearbeitet im juli 20 21 hat die adern
final bestätigt dass er die bedenken der
kommission komplett teilt und hat gesagt
dass die disziplinarkammer mit
grundlegenden rechtsstaats prinzipien
nicht vereinbar sei und er hat auch
sogar noch ein bisschen größeren bogen
gezogen den wohl auch die polen durchaus
so aufgefasst haben und das damit
begründet dass die mitglieder dieser
disziplinarkammer vom landes justizrat
also klar er es nennt man den in polen
bestimmt werden der seinerseits
maßgeblich mit regierungsnahen
mitgliedern besetzt ist und der
kontrolle der regierungsmehrheit
untersteht in polen und da hat der ogh
eben nicht nur die disziplinarkammer
kritisiert sondern schon recht klar
durchblicken lassen dass er auch an der
quasi rechtsstaatlichkeit dieses landes
justiz rats und an diesem ganzen system
schon massive zweifel hat kam in polen
nicht so an wie es ankommen sollte das
ist der teil des problems
was man darin und dass die
einsichtsfähigkeit fehlt uns mal sich
sehr in grenzen genau würde ich auch
sagen im juli hat der polnische
justizminister dann von aggressionen
gegen polen gesprochen von einem
juristischen hybriden krieg und sogar
von erpressung die arbeit der disziplin
kammer wurde nicht gestoppt obwohl es
eben jetzt schon das urteil gab und
jetzt wusste offenbar man gar nicht mehr
weiter wie gesagt die eskalation geht er
immer weiter und der vizepräsident des
euro je ha hat jetzt diese anordnung
getroffen eine million euro pro tagen um
sicherzustellen dass polen jetzt endlich
diese arbeit der disziplinarkammer
stoppt ja und da ist wieder der
justizminister und natürlich moment die
wichtige frage ist er jetzt natürlich
zahlen denn auch ordentlich da wird
natürlich noch kein einziger cent
gezahlt ich wollte es eigentlich ganz
relativ spannend das in der vergangenen
woche dort recht schnell ein sprecher
der kommission sich zu wort gemeldet hat
und sagte wir haben ein sehr effektives
verfahren am ende werden die betroffenen
beträge eingezogen also long story short
wenn ein land ein zwangsgeld nicht
bezahlt auch nach mehrfacher
aufforderung nicht dann wird die summe
sonst aus eu zahlungen an das eu-land
kompensiert das ist ein recht normaler
genau das wird verrechnet exakt das
zwangsgeld sollte hier eigentlich in den
eu haushalt fließen und sagt man halt
naja dann nehmen wir halt an kriegt
einfach weniger von dem was ihr sonst zu
bekommen hätte und da muss man ja sagen
das könnte sich jetzt langsam richtig
lohnen denn polen muss ja nicht nur die
eine million euro pro tag bezahlen wegen
der disziplinarkammer die immer noch
arbeitet sondern es ist ja auch schon
seit september 2020 weitere 500.000 euro
pro tag an eu kommission schuldig denn
der braunkohle abbau in thurow an der
grenze zu sachsen wurde auch immer noch
nicht gestoppt entgegen einem urteil des
bgh so dass auch schon teilnehmen muss
man sagen in auf unterschiedlichen
baustellen aber die tendenz ist immer
die gleiche polen hält sich nicht an
europäische regeln und der europäische
gerichtshof versucht das jetzt mit allen
möglichen mitteln einzufordern
und das ist eben nicht nur der
europäische gerichtshof sondern jetzt
kommt auch die eu-kommission unter druck
denn wir wollen ja nicht dass es
langweilig wird und in einer woche von
podcasts podcast hier nur eine
geschichte rund um polen passieren würde
nein am vergangenen freitag hat jetzt
das eu-parlament eine untätigkeitsklage
vor dem bgh gegen die kommission erhoben
das heißt natürlich landet die ganze
kiste am ende wieder bei morgen hardware
es insofern natürlich recht das ist
irgendwie der hat viel zu tun aber es
geht jetzt darum dass die kommission den
neuen eu rechtsstaatsmission es muss
nicht nutze also es geht darum dass seit
anfang des jahres die die union ja die
möglichkeit hat haushaltsmittel zu
kürzen wenn in einem mitgliedstaat ein
missbrauch des geldes droht weil dort
rechtsstaats verstöße drohen oder sonst
ich sage mal sehr massiv von grundwerten
der eu abgewichen wird das ganze ist
jetzt seit anfang des jahres in kraft es
wurde aber bisher nicht gezogen
ungarn und polen fürchten sowieso schon
dass diese regelungen vor allem gegen
sie angewendet werden vermutlich nicht
auch zu unrecht weil sie nicht ganz zu
unrecht weil sie natürlich auch
diejenigen sind die anlass dazu geben
diese regelungen anzuwenden da ist aber
auch wieder eine klage vor dem eugh gh
anhängig das heißt ungarn und polen
klagen vor dem bgh gegen diesen
rechtsstaats mechanismus da wurde vor
einigen wochen verhandelt da wird eine
entscheidung erwartet wahrscheinlich im
ersten quartal 2022 und die
eu-kommission hatte logischerweise
klingt ja auch erstmal plausibel gesagt
wir warten ab was der bgh entscheidet
bis wir tatsächlich diesen rechtsstaats
mechanismus ziehen und da jetzt polen
von zahlungen ausschließen so das war
auch eigentlich sogar so vereinbart
worden im jahr 2020 mit polen und und
auch ungarn weil die ansonsten
eu-haushalts entscheidungen blockiert
hätten ja das heißt man hat damals
gesagt okay wir warten wie der ogh das
sieht diesen rechtsstaats mechanismus
und ihr gibt dafür eure blockade gegen
die haushaltsentscheidungen auf sodass
eben zahlungen freigegeben werden konnte
jetzt macht aber das eu-parlament
erheblichen druck auf die kommission hat
wie gesagt eine untätigkeitsklage
eingereicht mal abwarten wie die
kommission jetzt reagiert man kann das
natürlich jetzt immer noch so ein
bisschen hinauszögern weil wie gesagt
der hai jetzt erstmal den ersten quartal
20 22 über die klage von ungarn und
polen gegen den rechts 100 mechanismus
entscheiden wird aber man muss schon
sagen da geht es jetzt langsam um echt
viel geld für die polen also aus dem
regulären eu haushalt hat polen zuletzt
ungefähr zwölf einhalb milliarden euro
pro jahr bekommen und außerdem warten
die polen
aufrichtig ein corona helfen also da
gibt es glaube ich um fast 25 milliarden
euro und das ganze geld wird jetzt im
moment nicht ausgezahlt das heißt da da
hängt jetzt gerade alles vorne und
hinten und jetzt hätte polen natürlich
gerne auf der einen seite die die kohle
von der eu auf der anderen seite sollen
sie es strafzahlungen leisten und man
darf natürlich nicht vergessen dass
alles kommt jetzt ich sage glaube drei
wochen nach dem urteil des spanischen
verfassungsgerichts das eu-recht für
teilweise unvereinbar gehaltenen
indischem recht also sehr grundsätzlich
statuiert hat das polnisches recht vor
eu recht gehe und eigentlich weiß
niemand wie er mit dieser entscheidung
so richtig umgehen soll es gibt nicht
wenige staatsrechtler die meinen dass
damit eigentlich sich sich polen auf
dieser ebene aus der eu heraus
katapultiert habe denn wie will man in
diesem wertesystem mit funktionieren
wenn man den den vorrang von eu-recht
nicht grundsätzlich akzeptiert dazu
lohnt es sich übrigens sehr nochmal in
die folge 181 reinzuhören vom 13 10 war
die glaube ich wo wir sowohl dieses
urteil des spanischen
verfassungsgerichts als auch mögliche
konsequenzen für die eu sehr sehr
ausführlich diskutiert haben ich glaube
das war's für den moment zu polen aber
das beschäftigt uns schon sehr sehr
lange und ich fürchte es würde uns auch
noch sehr lange beschäftigen
die eskalationsspirale dreht sich da
immer schneller weiter und jedenfalls im
moment hat glaube ich niemand so richtig
einen plan wie man da eigentlich wieder
rauskommen könnte ja so bedauerlich es
ist aber das glaube ich eine sehr gute
umschreibung
[Musik]
ich habe noch ein nachtrag
vergangener woche da muss ich eine
korrektur hier machen und zwar hatte ich
mit meinem förderung kollegen patrick
bahners er munter gesprochen über die
buchmesse und rechte verlage und
inwieweit die ausgeschlossen werden
sollten oder nicht und dann haben wir
uns einem zutiefst hinreißen lassen dass
der jung europa verlag um den es geht
ein mitglied im börsenverein des
deutschen buchhandels
ist aber dann meldete sich gleich am
nächsten tag die wirklich sehr
freundliche pressesprecherin des
börsenvereins schöne grüße gehen raus
und stellte klar
jung europa ist eben kein mitglied im
börsenverein des deutschen buchhandels
und war es auch nie und das wollen wir
hier an dieser stelle natürlich auch mal
feststellen
freuen uns aber dass auch im buchhandel
bei den verlagen dieser podcast bekannt
ist
wäre das nicht ein wundervoller
zeitpunkt um
leserbriefe und zuschriften zu bitten
absolut du hast es im blut schon ich
merke dass also auch hier hat die
freundliche pressesprecherin eine e mail
geschrieben an einspruch podcast faz.de
und hat darauf hingewiesen dass hat mich
wie gesagt sehr gefreut genauso wie sie
mich und uns ja viele andere hinweise
und kommentare zu unseren sendungen da
erreichen wirklich jeder einzelne wärmt
unser herz oder macht uns klüger je
nachdem was der inhalt ist also bitte
keep it coming wir wollen mehr davon
idealerweise beides sowohl herz wir
haben als auch uns klüger machen und
natürlich auch ernsthafte kritik nehmen
wir auch gerne an also ungern aber wir
tun und würde
im regieren dann mitunter auch
[Musik]
und dann sind wir jetzt bei unserer sehr
schmalen kategorie was kommt also was
beschäftigt uns in der nächsten woche
und da gucken wir auf dem bundesrat
genau der bundesrat hat am freitag wie
schon im intro angesprochen eine recht
schmale sitzung ich fand es aber hübsch
dass hamburg und bremen einen antrag
eingebracht haben und es war geht es um
die umgehung der mietpreis bremse das
ist jetzt irgendwie so ein eingang den
ich irgendwie niedlich fand und auch
erniedrigen soso ja ich finde den auch
so erfrischend zurückhaltend denn ich
mein um rund um den ganzen komplex
mietenwahnsinn wie ihr in berlin ja
immer so schön sagt
spricht man ja eigentlich meistens nur
auf einem relativ hohen niveau also
deutsche wohnen vergesellschaften
whatever mieten deckel auf landesebene
einführen und so also meistens relative
hemmer und wir wollen jetzt gerade
hamburg und bremen hat sich
angeschlossen er meine kleinen
stellschrauben versuchen schlupflöcher
zu schließen würde ich mal sagen da
finde ich auch ganz spannend dass das
aus hamburg kommt hamburg steht
eigentlich ganz gut da so in sachen
mieten steigung ich glaube die hatten
unter zwei prozent mieten steigerungen
in den vergangenen jahren also
verglichen mit anderen bundesländern
weniger super da vielleicht gibt es ja
auch daran dass sie da irgendwie mit
anderen massnahmen vorgehen ich glaube
es stand gestern noch in der
süddeutschen jetzt hamburg zum beispiel
noch eine rechtsverordnung erlassen die
die umwandlung von miet in
eigentumswohnungen
erschweren soll also die haben da schon
offensichtlich relativ kreative an gänge
so auch jetzt am freitag wo der
bundesrat entscheiden soll ob die länder
einen gesetzesentwurf aus hamburg und
bremen in den bundestag einbringen
wollen und zwar geht es darum den 566 de
ihr erinnert euch im jahr 2013 im
podcast aber noch nicht genau oder aber
wir haben schon häufiger darüber
gesprochen hat ja die mietpreis bremse
da ist sie mal wieder genau also also
weiter 566 de
statuiert jetzt heute das bürgerliche
gesetzbuch es muss man pardon natürlich
des bürgerlichen gesetzbuches richtig
studiert jetzt heute dass eine miete die
zu beginn eines mietverhältnisses
festgelegt wird in bestimmten gebieten
mit einem angespannten wohnungsmarkt die
also vorab festgelegt sein müssen wer
rechtsverordnung die ortsübliche
vergleichsmiete um maximal 10 prozent
überstiegen werden darf das gilt
eigentlich auch für die vermietung
geräten wohnraums aber dir dieser
sogenannte möblierung zuschlag der
zusätzlich auf die nettokaltmiete
aufgeschlagen wird ist gesetzlich
überhaupt nicht geregelt dass dieser
möblierung zuschlag muss auch nicht
gesondert ausgewiesen werden im
mietvertrag so dass man wenn man eine
möblierte wohnung bietet eigentlich
überhaupt nicht ausrichten kann
optimismus bremsen wird und das fängt
also das ist natürlich mal wieder tür
und tor offen für für findige juristen
die da irgendwie die schlupflöcher
finden
genauso für die attrappen wenn ich
stelle das man so fleißig
fleißig berlinerisch genau das geht um
es auch für jedes mieterhöhungsverlangen
auch da muss ich mir ausrechnen wird
jetzt die grenze die ich nicht
überschreiten der stopps in 15 prozent
oder so maximal in einem bestimmten
zeitraum überschritten kann man halt gar
nicht richtig ausrechnen wenn man diesen
möblierung zuschlag gar nicht kennt
deshalb wollen jetzt hamburg und bremen
regeln dass die nettokaltmiete und der
möblierung des zuschlags separat und
transparent ausgewiesen werden müssen
und so mieterinnen und mieter in die
lage versetzen die miethöhe vernünftig
zu überprüfen denn dann gilt für die
nettokaltmiete ganz normal die mietpreis
bremse also die maximal 10% über-
mietspiegel grenze und der möblierung
zuschlag deshalb gesondert auszuweisen
und soll seinerseits auch begrenzt
werden auf maximal ein prozent des
zeitwerts der überlassenen möbel pro
monat ist ja auch wieder irgendwie ganz
ganz hübsch damit meine ich sagte über
diese möblierung zuschlag haut man dann
einen wirklichkeit 15 prozent der miete
obendrauf oder so aber gab es heißt
alles bisher überhaupt nicht aus in
berlin auch mal 15 genau wie gesagt
alles 0 geregelt finde ich eigentlich
erstaunlich dass es so lange gedauert
hatte ich meine dass die
mietpreisbindung wurde 2013 eingeführt
jetzt 20 21
fand ich schon ganz spannend und ganz
nett wenn der zuschlag nicht ausgewiesen
wird in zukunft dann gilt die ganze
wohnung als unmöbliert vermietet dann
gehen also auch auf dem ganzen mietpreis
die mich brauchst bleiben so voll drauf
sammer und geht es jetzt auch durch oder
muss man befürchten dass die da keine
mehrheit bekommen ich man kann es noch
nicht sagen denn der ausschuss für
städte baut der wirtschaftsausschuss
haben gesagt finden wir eine super sache
bitte in den bundestag einbringen feder
führt das aber der rechtsausschuss und
der fans nicht gut und hat gesagt bitte
nicht in den bundestag einbringen das
heißt er kann ist noch ein bisschen
spannend werden am freitag wir halten
euch natürlich auf dem laufenden wenn
sich da tatsächlich was ändert prima
und wir kommen damit auch schon zum
wunderbaren gerechten urteil dieser
woche das ja nicht sehr schön wir
bleiben im mietrecht und ich musste bei
der vorbereitung auf die sendung echt
ein bisschen grinsen das betrifft
nämlich tatsächlich ein mietshaus in dem
man vielleicht nicht mehr unbedingt
wohnen würde wenn es anderswo
bezahlbaren wohnraum gebe auch immer
erzähl doch mal was das amtsgericht
berlin- köpenick so entschieden hier
aber die jetzt hast du das so
angeteasert dass auch ich neugierig bin
wie du diese würdest du da nicht mehr
wohnen weil der vermieter so schwierig
ist oder warum ein weil der
hausverwalter sich sehr merkwürdig
verhalten das ist so merkwürdig dass das
amtsgericht das zum zum anlass genommen
hat ohne dass es dafür überhaupt
irgendeinen grund gab zu sagen so geht
es ja nicht ok genau
da kommst du sozusagen
den rücken in die brust durchs auge oder
wie ja fast so wir machen einfach weiter
wir fangen wir von vorne an und zwar war
das ein streit wie ihr vielleicht
häufiger vorkommt zwischen mieter und
vermieter ja und da man sich schon seit
geraumer zeit es ging unter anderem um
die frage ob dieser mieter seine wohnung
unzulässiger weise an jemand anderen an
eine frau untervermietet hatte und dann
kohle damit gemacht hat sozusagen
vielleicht sogar an zwei frauen eine
blonde und eine dunkelhaarige es ging
drunter und drüber so und das sehen
vermieter natürlich nicht so gerne wenn
quasi auf ihre kosten dann kasse gemacht
wird also übrigens sind eher
untervermietung auch möglich aber da
bedarf es normalerweise der zustimmung
des vermieters das sei an dieser stelle
gesagt und der vermieter hatte die
befürchtung der so eine untervermietung
stattfindet und dass eben keine
zustimmung eingeholt worden ist und das
war der streit der zu grunde lag aber
auslöser jetzt auch die erneute
räumungsklage war dass
das wort [ __ ] you feel und zwar
nachdem der mieter im treppenhaus
gegenüber dem verwalter
da diesen ausdruck genannt hatte also
der die haben sich beschimpft im
treppenhaus verwalter und mieter und
vermieter hat ihn hat dann ihm einfach
gesagt [ __ ] you und hat sich umgedreht
und ist gegangen und dann hat er für
mich ja gesagt so geht es nicht hat
erneut gekündigt und wollte die wohnung
räumen lassen und die das bleibt jetzt
ohne erfolg und zwar vor dem amtsgericht
berlin- köpenick ich kann an dieser
stelle nochmal sagen diesen schönen fall
verdanken wir der arbeitsgemeinschaft
mietrecht und immobilien im deutschen
anwaltverein ist und darauf hingewiesen
unter anderem ja hier in dieser stelle
schöne grüße so und jetzt war natürlich
die schwierige frage
was ist mit diesem ausdruck [ __ ] you ja
ist der schwerwiegend und ehrverletzung
ja unter beugen ich möchte noch kurz
vorab anmerken dass die ja schon sich
noch angeschaut haben ob da dann wohl
was dran war dass da eine frau oder gar
zwei frauen eine blonde und eine
dunkelhaarige in der wohnung gewohnt
haben ist hätte sich dann heraus es war
wohl offensichtlich einfach die freundin
des wohnungsinhaber also des mieters
dienst schlüssel zur wohnung habe ja das
kann ja jeder sagen
genau ich glaube ungefähr so
substantiiert hat auch dieser vermieter
argumentiert und der hausverwalter hat
er da eben als zeuge geladen war und der
derjenige war der sehr mit viel wärme
darauf bestanden hat dass da ganz ganz
ganz bestimmt zwei frauen aus und
eingehen und er die da ständig sieht die
waren wohl beide nicht so richtig
ergiebig bei der zeugenbefragung also
dass hans gericht hat relativ kurz
gesagt na ja das ist irgendwie total
normaler lebenssachverhalt in seine
freundin sehr anschaulich geschildert
hat es ist eben seine freundin sie leben
nicht zusammen sie hat einen schlüssel
zur wohnung ende der durchsage genau
also diesen diesen dreh musste das
amtsgericht eben auch machen und jetzt
komme aber zur
unmutsäußerung [ __ ] you wie ist das
schön im juristendeutsch heißt und da
witzigen übrigens auch einige anwälte
auf twitter dass wenn man ganz schön
wäre wenn man eine rechtliche bewertung
des ausspruchs [ __ ] you im wandel der
zeit mal hier zeigen könnten also das
amtsgericht muss man eben sagen hat sich
das sehr genau und sehr gewissenhaft
angeguckt und
dann festgestellt es handle sich um eine
einmalige und jugend sprachlich
verbreitete unmutsäußerungen in einer
bereits sehr angespannten situation
ja das könnte ich meinen kindern so das
nächste mal auch sagen aber es wäre das
aber du wenn du es weißt verständnisvoll
wärs wer nicht sehr genau aufpassen
auf das ist ja hier offensichtlich eine
sehr angespannte situation aber es ist
nun einmal eine einmalige und jugend
sprachlich verbreitete unmutsäußerungen
des kein problem trotzdem spülmaschine
ausräumen und zwar sofort
irgendwer so ich bin mir sicher deine
kinder werden begeistert sein geht das
und ich fand aber fast noch schöner als
diese [ __ ] you entscheidung fand ich
diesen den schluss dieses urteils in dem
dann drin stand das muss ich unbedingt
noch zitieren dem kläger ist jedoch
jedoch mit aller deutlichkeit zu sagen
dass besucher der freundin weder einen
vertragswidrigen gebrauchte mietsache
darstellen noch anders zu kontrollen
durch den hausverwalter bieten die wird
es läuft ja das war der ja die vom
zeugen kam das war der hausverwalter
geschäftspraxis achtung besucher des
hauses anzuhalten und zu befragen
beziehungsweise gar deren ausweis zu
kopieren ist mit nachdruck zu
beachtlicher das hatte tatsächlich
gemacht denn der hat ausweise auch
kopiert und zeugen vernommen das ist ja
du musst ja erst mal auf die idee kommen
überhaupt einen hausverwalter anzuhören
und zu sagen kriegen wir diesen kerl
irgendwie raus guck doch mal was er so
treibt weil das war ein ein haushund mit
35 parteien und drei separaten eingängen
und der hausverwalter hat sogar im
verfahren ausgesagt er würde auch gar
nicht denselben aufgang benutzen wie der
beklagte mieter aber er war sich
trotzdem ganz ganz sicher dass auf jeden
fall dieser mieter ständig unerlaubten
damenbesuch hat wisst ihr bescheid das
meinte ich vielleicht würde man wenn man
in so einem haus wohnen muss wenn der
mieten wagt etwas weniger angespannt
wäre doch gerne umziehen ja obwohl
manchmal wenn man seinen vermieter auch
zeigen und nicht klein beigeben ja ihrem
blog watt im haus ist jetzt echt schön
also hier haben wir jedenfalls ein
zutiefst gerechtes urteil
ja wir freuen uns sehr dass dieser junge
mann dann noch weiter wohnen darf wer
immer das auch sein muss vielleicht ist
ja auch in schlägl das wissen wir ja
immer nicht
pia wir können das nur juristisch wir
können es nur in hand der sachlage und
der aktenlage sozusagen
nicht mal der aktenlage hab das gefühl
dass faselt etwas
genau sie sind
unser sendung angekommen ich kann
verkünden dass ich nächste woche im
urlaub in und helene bobrowski die
bezaubernde kollegin aus der politik
hier mich vertreten wird sie würdig
vertreten wird können sie sich könnt ihr
euch drauf freuen
ansonsten bedanken wir uns für die
aufmerksamkeit
eine schöne woche da bleibt uns gewogen
passt auf euch auf und bleibt gesund bis
dahin tschüss
[Musik]